hey guys it's Tuesday yarn its Grayson
it's time to talk back to you the day
that I talk back to you let's serve on
tumblr isn't this a painting somewhere
Queen Trinity new person there's a new
person probably they don't know what a
new person comments on one of my social
media platforms on credits the crap out
of them welcome to the its grace family
I don't know if it's a new person I
don't know I just sort of yes and it's
usually wrong what is praising also a
mystery let's do it Queen Trinity more
like train Quinta D you get it boo boo
bro I've never been so excited for
anything in my life I have front row VIP
seats for the nofilter show yes have you
guys done your tickets to our no filter
shows yet if not the links are down
below oh sorry I wrote them on my crotch
they'll be in the description box
underneath of this video is it great new
person-to-person devotion is a grace
more like is [ __ ] from you but you okay
Grace Hopper having a good week I really
appreciate you bringing joy into my life
when I needed it most thank you you will
never know how much I need to do I hope
you were feeling more relaxed and
healthy and are enjoying your break this
is formal because I'm not good at
expressing myself when I'm trying not to
cry sorry about that
Hey Craig's cool sometimes water comes
down to the river Jonah in your eyes and
that's okay thank you for being very
kind while trying not to cry I think
that's pretty neat and neat is cool and
cool it's hip and hips our bodies and
bodies
now let's go Twitter this is one right
this isn't all right here one villain
depression depended more like anytime I
eat a hero my butt turns into a villain
you boo boo I've only ever shot a BB gun
never a real gun before I don't know if
you guys know or saw or whatever memory
nice shot actual guns on hey USA and
that was the most serious part of the
show I hate guns and this definitely
confirmed that for me and I think for
memory also we were terrified
legitimately so terrified my hands were
shaking more than they normally do and
Mabry almost cried and I almost cried
and it was made for great web content
I'll stick to shooting shots of tequila
psychic Sarah to present a first new
person say KITT Sarah more like well
that sucks because I really hope and you
said it's Danielle that it was Danielle
and now Sarah here with an H
you made this awkward nominee I'm just
expressing true feelings where is Daniel
by the way can we get her you convince
my mom to let me go to your DC show
please and thanks okay for anyone's
parents that are on the fence about
allowing them to buy tickets to our no
filter shows please put your parents in
front of the computer screen now hello
parent first of all I want to
congratulate you for creating a spawn
you made another human being
congratulations that's a lot and you
raised them to be a very cool
responsible nice funny individual
unaccounted a watch meet memory and
henna just kidding also modest they're
all they're modest Hanna memory and I do
a state show called the no filter show
it's a live comedy show and there's
drinking and there is shark jokes and
fart jokes and queef jokes and beef
jokes but the end of the day it's it's a
fun time and at the end of the day would
you rather pay tens of dollars to have
your kid enjoy a night out away from the
computer for once around the real human
beings for once
or being some cyber chat room getting
catfished by an old man wearing a maroon
sweatpants and sweatshirt Carlo in
Arkansas those are literally the two
options so please allow them to buy
tickets or no filter shop also again
congratulations also did you should from
the delivery room table here dude that's
a thing
we'll talk later
now it's gonna your tail this is a
painting right how do you basic new
president person-to-person howtobasic
more like calling on the basic [ __ ]
hey you shut up I was waiting for the
egg so funny
cuz I know what it is but all those
uncle design men on it I'm part of it
where do we get it both of us then hide
all new positive person new person dan
hide will more like Kathleen hi Cole
you boo-boo here cement here's some
period advice for guys if you work in a
place with a lot of women listen for
co-workers complaining about periods
once you've figured out when all the
female co-workers have their periods
marked it on a calendar put it in Google
Calendar or something with a 28-day
repeat setting along do your best to be
invisible on those days okay
that is relatively decent advice I would
say when you know that a female
co-worker or friend or relative or
someone is on their period best juma not
treat them any differently really other
than be slightly more sensitive if your
dick bled once a month you'd want
someone to sympathize with you yeah
well that's if you're talking back to
you guys I hope that you enjoyed this
video and had a wonderful time here if
you did subscribe
is that what YouTube is that what yeah
okay yeah do that
that thing good look hey it's a party
better though
Oh a barbets mm sort of